hi everyone welcome to this next episode
of your daily equation yes of course
it's that time again and today I'm going
to focus upon a mathematical result that
not only has profound implications in
pure mathematics but also has profound
applications in physics as well and and
in some sense the mathematical result
that we're going to talk about is the
analog if you will of the well-known and
important physical fact that any complex
matter that we see in the world around
us from whatever computers to iPads to
trees to birds whatever any complex
matter we know can be broken down into
simpler constituents molecules or let's
just say atoms the atoms that fill out
the periodic table now what that really
tells us is you can start with simple
ingredients and by combining them in the
right way
yield complex looking material objects
the same is basically true in
mathematics when you think about
mathematical functions so it turns out
as proven by joseph fourier
mathematician born in the late 1700s
that basically any mathematical function
you know has to be sufficiently well
behaved and let's put all those details
to the side roughly any mathematical
function can be expressed as a
combination as a sum of simpler
mathematical functions and the simpler
functions that people typically use and
what I will focus upon here today as
well we choose sines and cosines right
those very simple wavy shape sines and
cosines if you adjust the amplitude of
the sines and cosines and the wavelength
and you combine them that is sum them
together in the right way you can
reproduce effectively any function that
you start with however complicated maybe
it can be expressed in terms of these
simple ingredients these simple function
sines and cosines so that's the basic
idea
let's just take a quick look at how you
actually do that in in practice so the
subject here is Fourier series and I
think the simplest way to get going is
to give an example to straight off the
bend for then I'm going to use a little
bit of graph paper so I can try to keep
this as neat as possible so let's
imagine that I have a function and
because I'm going to be using sines and
cosines which we all know they repeat
these are periodic functions I'm going
to choose a particular periodic function
to begin with to have a fighting chance
of being able to express it in terms of
sines and cosines and I'll choose a very
simple periodic function I'm not trying
to be particularly creative here many
people who are teaching this subject
start off with this example it's the
square wave and you'll note that I could
just keep on doing this this is the
repetitive periodic nature of this
function but I'll sort of stop here and
the goal right now is to see how this
particular shape this particular
function can be expressed in terms of
sines and cosines indeed it will just be
in terms of sines because of the way
that I have drawn this here now if I was
to come to you and say challenge you to
take a single sine wave and approximate
this red square wave what would you do
well I think you'd probably do something
like this you'd say let me look at a
sine wave whoops
Devlin that's not a sine wave the sine
wave that kind of comes up swings around
down here swings back over here and so
forth and carries on I won't bother
writing the periodic versions to the
right or to the left I'll just focus
upon that that one interval right there
now that blue sine wave you know it's
not a bad approximation to the red
square
if you know you never would confuse one
for the other but you seem to be heading
in the right direction but then if I
challenge you to go a little bit further
and add in another sine wave to try to
make the combined wave a little bit
closer to the square red shape what
would you do well here are the things
that you can adjust you can adjust how
many Wiggles the sine wave has that is
its wavelength and you can adjust the
amplitude of the new piece that you add
in so let's do that so imagine you add
in say a little piece that kind of looks
like this maybe it comes up like this
like that now if you add it together the
red not the red if you're out together
the green and the blue well certainly
you wouldn't get hot pink but let me use
hot pink for their combination well in
this part the green is gonna push the
blue up a little bit when you add them
together in this region the greens gonna
pull the blue down so it's gonna push
this part of the wave a little closer to
the red and it's in this regions gonna
pull the blue downward a little closer
to red as well so that seems like a good
additional wave to add in let me clean
this add the guy up and actually do that
addition so if I do that it'll push it
up in this region pull it down in this
region up in this region similarly down
in here and sort of something like that
so now the pink is a little bit closer
to the red and you could at least
imagine that if I was to judiciously
choose the height of additional sine
waves and the wavelength how quickly
they are oscillating up and down that by
appropriately choosing those ingredients
I could get closer and closer to the red
square wave and indeed I can show you I
can't do it by hand obviously but I can
show you up here on the screen an
example obviously done with a computer
and you see that if we add the first and
second sine waves together you get
something that's pretty close as we
in my hands wrong to the square wave but
in this particular case it goes up to
adding fifty distinct sine waves
together with various amplitudes and
various wavelengths and you see that
that particular color it's the dark
orange gets gets really close to being a
square wave so that's the basic idea
add together enough sines and cosines
and you can reproduce any wave shape
that you like okay so that's the basic
idea in pictorial form but now let me
just write down some of the key
equations and therefore let me start
with a function any function called f of
X and I'm going to imagine that it's
periodic in the interval from minus L to
L so not minus L 2 minus L there from
minus L to L but that means is its value
at minus L and its value at L will be
the same and then he just periodically
continues the same wave shape just
shifted over by the amount 2l along the
x-axis so again just so I can give you a
picture for that before write down the
equation so imagine then that I have my
axis here and let's for instance call
this point minus L and this guy the
symmetric side I'll call plus L and let
me just choose some wave shape in there
again use red so imagine I don't know it
sort of comes up and I'm just drawing
some random shape and the idea is that
it's periodic so I'm not gonna try to
copy that by hand rather I'll use the
ability I believe to copy and then paste
this over it we'll look at that that
worked out quite well so as you can see
it has over the interval a full interval
of size to L it just repeats and repeats
repeats that's my function my general
guy f of X and the claim is that this
guy can be written in terms of sines and
cosines and only be a little bit careful
about the arguments of the sines and
cosines and the claim is well maybe I'll
write down the theorem and then I'll
explain each of the terms that might be
the most efficient way to do it the
theorem that Joseph Fourier proves for
us is that f of X can be written well Y
I'm going to change in color I think
that's a little bit stupidly confusing
so let me use red for f of X and now let
me use blue say when I read in terms of
sines and cosines so it can be written
as a number just a coefficient usually
written as a naught divided by 2 plus
here the sums of the sines and cosines
so N equals 1 to infinity a n I'll start
with the cosine part cosine and here
look at the argument n PI x over L I'll
explain why and half a second it takes
that particular strange-looking form
plus a summation N equals 1 to infinity
be n times sine of n PI x over L where
that is squeezed in there so I'm
actually gonna use my ability to just
kind of squeeze this down a little bit
move it over and it looks a little bit
better okay now why do I have this
curious looking argument I'll look at
the cosine 1 y cosine of n PI x over L
well look if f of X has the property
that f of X equals f of X plus 2 L right
that's what it means that it repeats
every 2l units left or right then that
has to be the case that the cosines and
sines that use also repeat if X goes to
X plus 2 out and let's take a look at
that so if I have cosine of n PI x over
L what happens if I replace X by X
two out well let me stick that right
inside so I'll get cosine of n PI X plus
2 L divided by L what is that equal well
I get cosine of n PI x over L plus I get
n pi times 2 L over L the elves cancel
and I get 2 n pi now notice we all know
that cosine of n PI x over L R cosine of
theta plus 2 pi times an integer doesn't
change the vibe because and doesn't
change the hide the sine so it's this
equality which is why I use this n PI x
over L as it ensures that my cosines and
sines have the same periodicity as the
function f of X itself so that's why I
take this particular form but let me
erase all this stuff here because I just
want to go back to the theorem now that
you understand why it looks that way
I hope you don't mind when I do this in
class on a blackboard it's at this point
that the students say wait I haven't
written it all down yet but you can sort
of rewind if you wanted to so you could
go back so I'm not going to worry about
that but I want to finish off the
equation the theorem because what
Fourier does gives us an explicit
formula for a zero a N and B n that is
an explicit formula in the case of the a
ins and B ins for how much of this
particular cosine and how much of this
particular sine sine n PI X of other
cosine of n PI x over L and here is the
result so let me write it in a more
vibrant color so a 0 it's 1 over L the
integral from minus L to L of f of X DX
a n is 1 over L integral from minus L to
L f of X times cosine of n PI x over L
DX and BN is 1 over L integral minus
- L F of x times sine of n PI x over L
now again for those of you who are rusty
on your calculus or never took it sorry
that this may at this stage be a little
bit opaque but the point is that an
integral is nothing but a fancy kind of
summation so what we have here is an
algorithm that Fourier gives us for
determining the weight of the various
sines and cosines that are on the right
hand side and these integrals are
something that given the function f you
can sort of just not sort of you can
plug it in to this formula and get the
values of a 0 a N and B n that you need
to plug into this expression in order to
have the equality between the original
function and this combination of sines
and cosines now for those of you who are
interested to understand how you prove
this it's actually so straightforward to
proof you simply integrate f of X
against a cosine or a sine and those of
you who remember your calculus will
recognize that when you integrate a
cosine against a cosine that will be 0
if their arguments are different and
that's why the only contribution we'll
get is for the value of a n when this is
equal to N and similarly for sines the
only nonzero if you integrate f of X
against a sine will be when the argument
of that agrees with the sine here and
that's why this end picks out this end
over here so anyway that's the rough
idea of the proof if you know your
calculus remember that cousins and sines
yield an orthogonal set of functions you
can prove this but my goal here is not
to prove it my goal here is to show you
this equation and for you to have an
intuition that it is formalizing what we
did in our little toy example earlier
were we by hand had to pick the
amplitudes and the wavelengths of the
various signs waves that we were putting
together now this formula tells you
exactly how
much of a given say sine-wave to put in
given the function f of X you can
calculate it with this beautiful little
formula so that's the basic idea of
Fourier series again it's incredibly
powerful because sines and cosines are
so much easier to deal with than this
arbitrary say wave shape that I wrote
down as our motivating shape to begin
with it's so much easier to deal with
waves that have a well-understood
property both from the standpoint of
functions and in terms of their graphs
as well the other utility of the Fourier
series for those of you who are
interested is that it allows you to
solve certain differential equations
much more simply than you would
otherwise be able to do if there are
linear differential equations and you
can solve them in terms of sines and
cosines you can then combine the sines
and cosines to get any initial wave
shape that you like and therefore you
might have thought you were limited to
the nice periodic sines and cosines that
have this you know nice simple wavy
shape but you can get something that
looks like this out of sines and cosines
so you can really get anything out of it
at all the other thing that I don't have
time to discuss but those of you who
perhaps have taken some calculus will
note that you can go a little bit
further than Fourier series something
called a Fourier transform where you
turn the coefficients a N and B n
themselves into a function the function
is a weighting function which tells you
how much of a given amount of sine and
cosine you need to put together in the
continuous case when you let L go to
infinity these are details that if you
haven't said of the subject may go by
too quickly but I'm mentioning it
because it turns out that Heisenberg's
uncertainty principle in quantum
mechanics emerges from these very kinds
of considerations now of course Joseph
Fourier was not thinking about quantum
mechanics with the uncertainty principle
it's sort of a remarkable
fact that I'll mention again when I talk
about the uncertainty principle which
I've not done in this your daily
equation series but I will at some point
in the not-too-distant future but it
turns out that the uncertainty principle
is nothing but a special case of Fourier
series an idea that mathematically was
spoken of you know 150 years or so
earlier than the uncertainty principle
itself is just sort of a beautiful
confluence of mathematics that's derived
and and and thought about in one context
and yet when properly understood gives
you deep insights into the fundamental
nature of matter as described by quantum
physics ok so that's all I wanted to do
today the fundamental equation given to
us by Joseph Fourier in the form of the
Fourier series so until next time that
is your daily equation